tu as fui des foyers d'accueil dans six
comtés je peux prendre soin de moi quand
tu as 18 ans donne une chance à ces gens
parce que c'est ce qu'ils te donnent
c'est billy batson merci de
faire des compétences à la maison ils ont l'air gentils mais
ne  ne l'achetez pas, il devient vrai Game of
Thrones ici mec
juste déconner tu me regardes et
tu es comme pourquoi si sombre tu es handicapé
woster kid tu as tout si tu
pouvais avoir un super pouvoir que
penses-tu  tout le monde choisit le vol tu sais
pourquoi pour qu'ils puissent s'envoler de cette
conversation pas parce que les héros volent
bien tu fais juste une fausse famille
pour te défendre Billy Batson
je te choisis un stupide
bonjour dis mon nom pour que mes pouvoirs puissent
te traverser mais je ne le fais pas  Je ne connais pas votre nom,
monsieur,
attendez pour de vrai, d'accord,
vous êtes la seule personne que je connaisse qui sache
quoi que ce soit à propos de ce truc de Cape Crusader ce
soir
ouais c'est fou, quels sont vos
super pouvoirs mec, je ne
sais même pas comment faire pipi dans ce truc d'accord
pourquoi parles-tu, je vais m'éclater
tes cartes postales ton téléphone chargé comme un
méchant
tu as une immunité totale je vais prouver que
tu es mort désolé pour ta fenêtre
tu es le bienvenu pour ne pas te faire voler